[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing the death
of Peter Pettigrew AKA wormtail former
Marauder Order of the Phoenix member and
later Death Eater in the Magical World
of Harry Potter the fate of characters
often serves as a reflection of their
choices and allegiances one such
character whose Destiny diverges
significantly between JK Rowling's books
and the film adaptations is Peter known
for his canning and treachery
pettigrew's demise in the books is a
fitting end to his character Arc
emphasizing the consequences of his
betrayal and disloyalty however in the
film adaptation his death is notably
omitted leaving his fate shrouded in
ambiguity and raising questions about
the impact of this choice on the story's
overall message today we're going to
dive into a detailed comparison of Peter
pettigrew's death in the Harry Potter
books and movies exploring the
significance of his character's fate and
the implications of its Omission from
the film join me as we unravel the
threads of pettigrew's Twisted tale and
analyze the narrative choices that
shaped his Destiny in both mediums
when Peter Pettigrew first came to
Hogwarts School of Witchcraft and
Wizardry it is said that the Sorting Hat
took an entire five minutes before
deciding to place him in Gryffindor
as we are to understand it The Hat was
wafering between Gryffindor and Southern
showing very early on that Pettigrew had
inclination towards the characteristics
most seen in students of the green and
silver house that later became obvious
after Sirius Black revealed Peter to be
a traitor and Death Eater who had framed
him for pettigrew's crimes faked his own
death and lived as a rat for 12 years
Peter was actually quite clever
ambitious and resourceful the main
characteristics of a southern pupil in
any case having been sorted into
Gryffindor he very obviously lacked the
qualities of his fellow housemates he
was not particularly Brave or courageous
and being that he was somewhat of an
underdog himself he never stood up for
the little guy after all Peter was the
somewhat overlooked member of the
Gryffindor gang the Marauders a group of
friends that consisted of James Potter
Sirius Black Remus Lupine and of course
Peter himself
the group bonded after discovering that
Lupine was both a wizard and a werewolf
forming the Marauders and going to Great
Lengths to all secretly become anime guy
that is James Sirius and Peter each
taught themselves how to turn into an
animal at will
Peter's animagus form ended up being
that of a rodent which was actually
quite fitting eventually double crossing
the Order of the Phoenix and defecting
to Lord Voldemort's Service as a spy but
I do Wonder was it this very perception
of Peter that he was rat like in nature
not that bright and referred to by his
best mates as wormtale that led to
pettigrew's cowardice and betrayal of
those he was closest to in Cruel
contrast all of pettigrew's closest
friends were idolized for their
popularity James Potter was a quidditch
star and Sirius was a handsome bad boy
type in this environment it must have
been difficult for Peter to maintain a
sense of self-worth and confidence this
brings us to Peter's decision to become
a Death Eater it's been expressed that
Pettigrew double crossed the Order of
the Phoenix and all of his closest
friends to follow Voldemort for one
simple cowardly and selfish reason he
didn't believe there was any way to beat
the dark lord so wormtel decided to join
him before it was too late
the decisions of Peter pettigrew's
character helped to offer a unique
perspective on themes of loyalty
betrayal and the consequences of one's
choices and here's what the film
adaptation really messed up by omitting
pettigrew's death from the film The
Story loses a crucial moment that
underscores the consequences of betrayal
and disloyalty the book version of his
death serves as a poignant reminder of
the price one pays for aligning with
evil and the potential for Redemption
even in the darkest of times in contrast
the film's decision to leave pettigrew's
fate unresolved weakens the narrative's
exploration of these themes and leaves
us with a far less satisfying conclusion
to his character Arc let's dive in
further and explore Peter pettico's
death book versus film death in the
books in the seventh book Harry Potter
and the Deathly Hallows Pettigrew meets
his end during the Battle of Malfoy
Manor this event takes place when Harry
Ron and Hermione are captured and held
prisoner in the cellar of the Malfoy
family's estate trapped in the cellar
Harry decides to use the remaining Shard
of a magical mirror given to Harry by
his late Godfather series Black to call
for help the help came in the form of
Dobby who helped the Gang form a plan to
escape the seller and save Hermione he
was being tortured by Bellatrix the
strange when Dobby arrives he makes a
racket that causes Lestrange to send
Pettigrew down to The Cellar to check on
the captives while checking on the
prisoners he attempts to subdue Harry
however Pettigrew hesitates for a moment
when Harry reminds him of the life debt
he owes him this life debt dates back to
the events in Harry Potter and the
Prisoner of Azkaban when Harry prevented
Sirius Black and rumors Lupine from
killing Pettigrew pettigrew's momentary
hesitation a fleeting glimmer of remorse
causes his magical silver hand to sense
his disloyalty the hand which was given
to him by Voldemort as a reward for his
services and turns on Pettigrew and
strangles him to death the silver
fingers slackened Harry had not expected
it he wrenched himself free astonished
keeping his hand of a wormtail's mouth
he saw the rat-like man's small watery
eyes widened with fear and surprise he
seemed just as shocked as Harry and what
his hand had done at the tiny merciful
impulse it had betrayed and he continued
to struggle more powerfully as those who
undo that moment of weakness and will
have that whispered Ron tuggingworm
tells one from his other hand wandless
helpless pettigrew's pupils dilated in
Terror his eyes had slid from Harry's
face to something else his own silver
fingers were moving inexorably toward
his own throat no without pausing to
think Harry tried to drag back the hand
but there was no stopping it the silver
tool that Voldemort had given his most
cowardly servant had turned upon its
disarmed and useless owner Pettigrew was
reaping his reward for his hesitation
his moment of petty he was being
strangled Before Their Eyes no Ron had
released wormtail too and together he
and Harry tried to pull the crushing
metal fingers from a roundwormtail's
throat but it was no use pedigree was
turning blue relatio said Ron pointing
the wand at the silver hand but nothing
happened
dropped to his knees and at the same
moment Hermione gave a dreadful scream
from overhead wormtail's eyes rolled
upward in his purple face he gave a last
twitch and was still in the end
pettigrew's fate comes as a direct
result of his allegiance to Voldemort
highlighting the themes of loyalty and
the consequences of one's choices this
dramatic passage serves as a powerful
reminder of the price one pays for
aligning with dark Forces it also
emphasizes the importance of loyalty and
the potential for Redemption even for a
character as morally compromised as
Pettigrew death in the films or lack
thereof in the film version of Harry
Potter and the Deathly Hallows
pettigrew's death is conspicuously
absent instead during the Battle of
Malfoy Manor Dobby the house self stuns
Pettigrew and he collapses to the ground
muttering as he falls the film provides
no further information about his fate
leaving it unresolved and open to
interpretation based on the film alone
it's almost as if Peter never died the
best clue that Pettigrew has in fact
died is that he's no longer in the films
following his fall implications of the
Omission the treatment of Peter
pettigrew's death in the Harry Potter
books and films serves as a valuable
case study on the impact of narrative
choices and the importance of staying
true to the core themes of a story while
the book version of pettigrew's demise
provides a fitting end to his character
Arc and reinforces the consequences of
betrayal the film adaptations omission
of this event leaves a gap in the story
the fate of Pettigrew in the film just
wasn't satisfying why the next question
I have on this topic is why why go
through the trouble of altering such an
import insane why purposely fail to give
viewers closure on a character that's
been featured in the majority of the
books and films the explanation is
simple but in my view inadequate
pettico's book death was simply deemed
too frightening for younger film goers
while I appreciate the efforts of
filmmakers to be mindful of a younger
audience this answer also doesn't
entirely make sense to me this was the
last book and up until this point the
films had already begun their Plunge
Into Darkness in fact I'd argue that the
gruesome sight of Charity Burbage
suspended and contorted mid-air above a
table full of Death Eaters was much
darker than pettigrew's death by trying
to protect younger viewers filmmakers
did a disservice to the story arc for
Harry and wormtel neglecting to include
a moment that was set up as far back as
Prisoner of Azkaban when Harry chose to
stop Sirius Black from killing Pettigrew
and allowed him to live in conclusion
the book version of Peter pettico death
serves as a much more fitting end to his
character Arc emphasizing the
consequences of his betrayal and
disloyalty the film adaptation by
contrast leaves his fate entirely
unresolved leaving the viewer with an
intense feeling of dissatisfaction
what do you think should Peter's death
have been included in the Harry Potter
films was the omission of this important
scene a problem for you leave a comment
down below also if you enjoy the content
please be sure to like the video and
subscribe to the channel until next time
remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live